breaking news
breaking news und verbrechen schauen
live in den bundestag in der debatte um
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine spricht
jetzt cdu chef friedrich merz den
kollegen
diesen jungs und mädels muss ich mal
sagen
weil ich nicht tue was ihr wollt deshalb
führe ich
so hat sich der bundeskanzler einige
tage vor ostern in einem
rundfunkinterview
auf die frage ein gelassen ob er und wie
er denn in diesem land führen mit jungs
und mädels waren dabei offenbar die drei
ausschussvorsitzenden gemeint die eine
reise in die west kleine unternommen
haben mal ganz unabhängig davon wer das
war mitglieder des deutschen bundestages
herablassend mit jungs und mädels zu
bezeichnen das ist auch für einen
bundeskanzler der bundesrepublik
deutschland vorlegen
und meine damen einfach nur das
gegenteil von dem zu tun was mythen der
des deutschen bundestages für richtig
halten ist auch kein ausdruck von
führungen
dieser sprachgebrauch ist eher ein
zeichen von unsicherheit und
formschwäche der bundeskanzler der
bundeskanzler hat über wochen die
diskussion über die frage ob der ukraine
denn nun waffen geliefert werden sollten
oder nicht hingehalten offengelassen
ausweichend beantwortet ich erinnere nur
an die
regierungsbefragung die wir vor drei
wochen hier hatten der bundeskanzler hat
alle fragen beantwortet die ihm nicht
gestellt worden sind und keine einzige
frage von denen beantwortet die wir im
gestellt hat meine damen und herren
das ist
das ist nicht besonnenheit wie sie es in
den ampel fraktionen versuchen in den
letzten tagen zu erklären das ist zögern
das ist zaudern und das ist
ängstlichkeit nun regen sie sich darüber
auf dass
wir hier das im plenum ansprechen aber
meine damen und herren das problem für
den bundeskanzler war und ist nicht die
opposition das problem für den
bundeskanzler war und ist bis zum
heutigen tag die kritik aus den eigenen
reihen
an dabei waren dabei waren worte wie
führungsschwäche und kommunikations
desaster noch harmlose formulierungen
politische hütchen spiele sind dem
bundeskanzler vorgeworfen worden bis hin
zu der offenen frage ob er denn seinem
amt noch gewachsen sei ich will es dabei
bewenden lassen es ist
gewiss nicht
also wenn sie wenn sie
staatspolitische verantwortung der
opposition nur so verstehen dass wir
ihnen in allem was sie hier vorliegen
und vorschlagen kritiklos zustimmen dann
ist das ein großer irrtum meine damen
und herren und wir erlauben uns gezogen
wir erlauben uns schon diese fertig die
da geäußert wird aufzunehmen und zum
gegenstand auf einer parlamentarischen
diskussion zu machen meine damen und
herren und es ist trotzdem gut dass wir
heute gemeinsam den versuch unternehmen
einen entschließungsantrag zu
verabschieden der sich umfassend mit der
hilfe für die ukraine gefasst wenn die
bundesregierung in wenn die
bundesregierung in den letzten tagen und
wochen zu diesen fragen eine klare und
einvernehmliche haltung eingenommen
hätte und wenn der bundeskanzler dies
hier klar und unmissverständlich gesagt
hätte dann wäre weder der antrag
notwendig gewesen noch diese ganze
debatte heute machen
wir und wenn hier in den letzten wochen
nicht einen antrag vorgelegt hätten dann
wären sie doch nie auf den gedanken
gekommen nun ihrerseits tätig zu werden
sollten
deutschen bundestag dazu meine damen und
herren wir führen die eine wir führen
hier eine wichtige diskussion und wir
nehmen hier auch unsere verantwortung in
dieser diskussion war und ich will
deswegen
ich will ihnen noch einmal auch zu der
debatte von gestern ihr etwas sagen wir
hatten gestern die diskussion über das
100 milliarden programm für die
bundeswehr und dem dazu vorgeschlagene
text der änderung des grundgesetzes
meine damen und herren wir haben die
sechs punkte die für uns wichtig sind
wenn wir dem denn dann zustimmen sollen
genannt ich sage ihnen nochmal nehmen
sie das bitte nicht auf die leichte
schulter
wir sind grundsätzlich bereit mit ihnen
einen solchen weg zu gehen aber wir
lassen uns auch nicht einfach nur so zur
zustimmung auf fordern wir haben einige
punkte genannt und ich will es hier an
dieser stelle noch einmal sehr deutlich
wiederholen unsere zustimmung ist auch
davon abhängig dass wir in wenigen
jahren nicht wieder da stehen wo wir
heute stehen nämlich mit einer
unterfinanzierten bundeswehr und
deswegen wollen wir deswegen wollen wir
sehen
dass der bund das der einzelplan 14 für
die verteidigung kontinuierlich
aufwächst und nicht die einmalig ein
bestimmter betrag zur verfügung gestellt
wird wir wollen die beschaffungs
systematik ändern übrigens der
bundeskanzler war begeistert als wir
ihnen das vorgeschlagen haben dass wir
an diesem beschaffungs system etwas
ändern wollen dann machen wir es doch
jetzt gemeinsam und nervösen und
kritisieren sie doch nicht ständig in
der opposition herum gewesen diese
beiden punkte nennen wir haben hier noch
einen ziemlich langen weg wir haben hier
noch einen ziemlich langen weg vor uns
und es sind halt dem vorschlag den der
bundeskanzler vor acht wochen
unternommen hat wertvolle zeit
verstrichen wir sind zu keinem dieser
punkte bisher überein gekommen
geschweige denn dass wir hier ein
gemeinsames gesamtkonzept für ausgeformt
und aufgeschrieben haben wir sind noch
ziemlich weit entfernt von einer
einigung meine damen und herren
mit dem entschließungsantrag des
heutigen tages sind wir
dankenswerterweise einen schritt weiter
richtigerweise enthält dieser text nicht
nur bewertungen und einschätzungen zu
waffenlieferungen
richtigerweise auch wir wissen dass
waffengewalt in einer solchen
auseinandersetzung immer nur das letzte
mittel sein darf und letztendlich auch
das eingeständnis des scheiterns von
diplomatie und der suche nach
politischen lösungen umfasst das ist so
aber an dieser stelle stehen wir seit
dem 24 februar 2022 und ich will es mal
mit diesen worten deutlich sagen niemand
von uns befürwortet leichtfertig den
einsatz militärischer gewalt niemand wir
alle wissen dass mit dem einsatz von
waffen
also diese zwischenrufen verstehe ich
wirklich überhaupt wenn wir hier eine
wenn wir hier eine gewissenhafte
diskussion führen wollen und bei einem
solchen satz von ihnen solche solche
zwischenrufe kommen dann frage ich mich
wie ernst sie eigentlich wirklich die
bereitschaft hier vortragen mit uns zu
einer gemeinsamen lösung in diesen
schwierigen zeiten
anders wir haben doch alle diese wir
haben doch alle diese schrecklichen
bilder vor augen und sie beschweren uns
doch jeden tag die bilder dieser
menschenrechtsverletzung die bilder aus
diesen aus diesem kraftwerk aus diesem
stahlwerk da einmal in mario pohl das
sind doch furchtbare bilder aber gerade
weil wir diese bilder vor augen haben
müssen wir doch heute sagen einem
aggressor wie putin und seine
machtapparat muss man dann in einer
solchen situation auch als ultima ratio
mit militärischer gewalt begegnen es
geht nicht anders in einer solchen
situation heraus bestreitet hier niemand
aber wir müssen doch gemeinsam auch nach
draußen erklären warum wir heute zu
einem solchen entschließungsantrag hier
gemeinsam kommen und wenn sie das schon
vor einigen wochen getan hätten noch mal
dann brauchen wir es doch heute
gemeinsam nicht zu tun an der stelle
stehen wir doch heute wenn die ukraine
und ihre mutige armee das nicht täte und
wenn wir der ukraine dabei nicht helfen
würden dann wird diese unterlassene
hilfe wie schon in der vergangenheit als
schwäche und als zögerlichkeit ausgelegt
und dann wird es nach der ukraine
weiteren länder und weitere regionen
geben die von diesem regime bedroht
meine damen in diesem zusammen in diesem
zusammenhang ist der hinweis des
bundeskanzlers dass unsere deutschen
waffen möglicherweise einen dritten
weltkrieg auslösen würden ebenso
unverantwortlich wie aus unserer eigenen
historischen erfahrungen heraus falsch
und irreführend
der hinweis ist unverantwortlich
der hinweis ist unverantwortlich denn er
lässt ja nur den schluss zu dass aus der
sicht des bundeskanzlers alle anderen
länder die mehr für die ukraine tun als
wir und davon gibt es viele die
kriegsgefahr in europa erhöhen meine
damen und herren das ist doch eine
geradezu groteske umkehrung von ursache
und verantwortung für diesen krieg keine
proteste oder
oder
dies berichtete spd oder warum sollten
gerade deutsche waffen diese wirkung
haben alle anderen aber nicht meine
damen und herren der historie der
hinweis ist auch historisch falsch weil
doch gerade wir wissen dass besänftigung
und beschwichtigung in der
internationalen sprache der politik
heißt das achievement die ausweitung
einer aggression überhaupt erst möglich
macht und deshalb ist es gut deshalb ist
es gut dass wir heute mit diesem
gemeinsamen antrag und der
beschlussfassung darüber klarheit
schaffen die deutsche bundesregierung
kann sich ab heute auf ein breites
zustimmendes votum des deutschen
bundestages stützen und der ukraine die
waffen liefern die sie braucht und die
wir dann auch zur verfügung stellen
können und deswegen will ich dies
abschließend sagt man sagen kann ist
auch wissen sagen ich will mich
ausdrücklich bedanken bei den fraktionen
der spd der grünen und der fdp und bei
ihren jeweiligen vorsitzenden dass wir
in den letzten tagen zu dieser
gemeinsamen haltung hier auch gefunden
haben die arbeit an den texten und die
vielen gespräche die wir in den letzten
tagen dazu geführt haben meine damen und
herren hat sich gelohnt hat sich
merz und er hat dort etwas angesprochen
dass in der vergangenen woche zu einem
sturm der empörung geführt ein hashtag
jungs und mädels ja er bezieht sich auf
ein zitat von olaf scholz ist eine woche
alt ist und das reichlich arrogant
wirkte dieser satz hier gefallen im
interview mit dem rbb diesen jungs und
mädels den muss ich mal sagen weil ich
nicht tue was ihr wollt deshalb führe
ich aber jetzt tut er eben doch was vor
allen dingen die opposition seit einer
woche wurde wollte gefordert hat schwere
waffen zu liefern das ist zumindest der
einstieg daran dieses versprechen jetzt
gepard panzer zu liefern und das war ja
auch die linie von friedrich mehr als
der gerade gesagt hat mensch der kanzler
der läuft uns hinterher der macht was
wir längst gefordert hat der ist ein
getriebener und jetzt antwortet der spd
chef lars klingbeil rhein seit über zwei
monaten führt wladimir putin einen
brutalen angriffskrieg gegen die ukraine
täglich sehen wir das leid dass putin
und seine weise wie man die menschen im
land bringen gezielte tötung von
zivilisten die bombardierungen von
krankenhäusern von schulen von
kindergärten
wladimir putin trägt die verantwortung
für diesen krieg er wird als
kriegsverbrecher in die geschichte
eingehen und wir werden alles daran
setzen dass er vor den zuständigen
gerichten dieser welt für diesen
brutalen krieg zur verantwortung gezogen
es ist gut
es ist gut dass wir heute hier im
parlament ein eindeutiges ein um
missverständnisse
unmissverständliches signal aus der
mitte des deutschen bundestages setzen
putin muss diesen völkerrechtswidrigen
angriffskrieg beenden wir stehen an der
seite derjenigen die mutig und tapfer in
der ukraine kämpfen wir stehen an der
seite der ukraine das machen wir mit
diesem gemeinsamen antrag deutlich
herr merz mir war wichtig diesen punkt
am anfang meiner rede zu nennen bei
ihnen
bei ihm hatte ich
bei ihnen hat es fünf minuten gedauert
bis sie zum ersten mal etwas zum krieg
und zum leiden der menschen in der
ukraine gesagt habe und ich habe hier
eigentlich auf meinem zettel draufstehen
ich habe hier eigentlich auf meinem
zettel draufstehen dank an die union
weil er merz und ich muss ihnen das in
aller emotionalität auch sagen das hätte
heute eine staatspolitische rede von
ihnen werden können es ist aber es ist
eine parteipolitische rede geworden wir
haben
sie haben zu ihren eigenen leuten
gesprochen und ich will ihnen sagen herr
merz ich bin dankbar dafür dass wir
einen gemeinsamen antrag auf den weg
gebracht haben ein dank an die vier
fraktionen und die vorsitzenden
aber hier ist kein platz für
parteipolitische profilierung und ich
will dass
ich will dass
märz ist will das aus meiner eigenen
geschichte beschreiben ich bin 2009 in
dieses parlament gekommen die spd ist
damals in die opposition gegangen das
war schwierig für uns wir lange regiert
haben wir haben eine schwarz gelbe
regierung erlebt die nicht immer
harmonisch worden und trotzdem haben wir
als spd damals bei den großen
internationalen fragen die abgestimmt
wurden nach dem prinzip gehandelt erst
das land dann die partei erinnern sie
sich erinnern sie sich herr merz
erinnern sie sich an das karfreitags
gefecht das erste mal dass deutsche
soldaten im ausland gefallen sind
trotzdem hat die spd am afghanistan
mandat festgehalten hat das klare
bekenntnis zur bundeswehr abgegeben
erinnern sie sich an die großen debatten
über die schutzschirme für griechenland
für spanien der euro rettungsschirm wir
hätten uns das einfach machen können
aber wir haben damals nie gegen die
regierung gestimmt lieber herr merz und
ich habe mir sorgen gemacht die letzten
tage um die union als sie kritisiert
haben als sie kritisiert haben als sie
kritisiert haben dass olaf scholz nach
japan fährt das olaf scholz sich mit
einem der wichtigsten westlichen
verbündeten trifft da ich mich gefragt
was ist nur aus der union von angela
merkel geworden was passiert da gerade
in
lieber im märz
lieber im märz diejenigen die am antrag
mitgeschrieben haben die haben nach dem
prinzip gehandelt erst das land dann die
partei und ich hätte mir gewünscht dass
diejenigen die ihre rede geschrieben
haben auch nach diesem grundsatz die
räder aufgestellt
aber zur sache
zur sache und ich will ein paar sätze
ein paar sätze zu diesem antrag auf
sagen weil es mir weil es mir wirklich
wichtig dieser antrag stützt das handeln
der bundesregierung diese regierung
handelt sie liefert sie führt und ich
will dass an dieser stelle auch sagen
weil antragsberatung
antragsberatung auch einen moment sind
wo man mal danke sagen kann die
vertreterinnen und vertretern der
bundesregierung haben entscheidungen zu
treffen von einer reichweite für die
nächsten 10 15 20 jahre von einer
tragweite die über leben und tod geht es
sind entscheidungen die man sich nicht
einfach macht in der regierung und ich
will stellvertretend hier nancy faeser
christian lindner annalena baerbock
christine lambrecht robert habeck und
vor allem bundeskanzler olaf scholz
danken für das was wir in den letzten
wochen an guter führung durch die
bundesregierung gemeinsam erlebt haben
und weil ich
und weil ich in den letzten tagen ja
viel doch in bewertungen der
bundesregierung gelesen habe übrigens
ich empfehle mal die aktuelle ausgabe
der times da kriegt man mal einen
überblick auf wie deutschlands rolle in
der welt gesehen wird lassen sie uns mal
noch die fakten schon fakt eins
deutschland hat mit den partnern
sanktionen vorbereitet und setzt diese
massiv durch selten gab es ein so großes
umfassendes sanktionspaket wie jetzt
gegen russland russland wird ökonomisch
abgekoppelt von den internationalen
märkten und wird das über einen langen
zeitraum bitter zu spüren bekommen was
die konsequenzen dieser sanktionen sind
fakt 2 deutschland reduziert die
abhängigkeit von russischem gas und
russischem öl und das tun wir in einem
größeren tempo als im koalitionsvertrag
schon angelegt war und ich bin dankbar
dafür dass wir das gemeinsam jetzt in
aller entschiedenheit auch täglich tun
fakten nummer drei ist dass wir
eingebettet in die internationale
kooperation agieren der westen war lange
nicht mehr so geeint und so stark wie
jetzt die nato die europäische union und
sagt ja auch da müssen wir was draus
machen wir können nicht nur zusammen
kommen weil putin uns treibt sondern wir
brauchen jetzt eine transatlantische
agenda für die zukunft wir brauchen
jetzt eine starke europäische union das
ist ein geschenk was da ist aber es ist
das handeln der bundesregierung
und ja deutschland liefert waffen diese
bundesregierung hat mit einem prinzip
gebrochen das über jahrzehnte in
deutschland galt wir liefern seit dem
beginn des krieges und wir sind jeden
tag einen schritt weiter gegangen in der
qualität in der quantität dessen was wir
tun aber wir hatten auch hier prinzipien
und in dieser kontinuität stehen auch
die entscheidung der letzten tage wir
haben gesagt wir stimmen uns ab mit den
internationalen partnern wir haben
gesagt wir gefährden nicht die eigene
landes und bündnisverteidigung und wir
haben gesagt dass wir selbst nicht zur
kriegspartei werden alles das tut die
bundesregierung und ich bin dankbar
dafür und das ist mein letzter punkt der
nicht ansprechen will ich bin dankbar
dafür dass wir eine regierung haben die
weiß dass sie konsequent und schnell
entscheiden ist die aber nichts herr
merz sowie das manchmal bei ihnen der
eindruck ist morgens aufwacht und
überlegt was können wir heute tun gerade
in diesen zeiten gerade in zeiten von
leben und tod von krieg und frieden geht
es darum dass man grundüberzeugung und
prinzipien hat und die auch in einer
zeitenwende nicht über den haufen wirft
liebe
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
trotz aller parteipolitische differenzen
will ich dass sie am ende noch einmal
betone es ist richtig und wichtig dass
es hier aus der mitte des parlamentes
ein klares signal an wladimir putin ein
klares signal an die menschen in der
ukraine gibt dass wir auf der richtigen
seite der geschichte als deutscher
bundestag stehen aber ich sage ihnen
auch ein kleingeist und eine
kleinkariertheit wie sie manches mal
gerade erlebt wird in der politischen
debatte das bringt uns nicht weiter wir
haben schwierige entscheidung vor uns
beispielsweise mit dem sondervermögen
und herr merz ist es mein letzter appell
machen sie deutlich dass sie an der
seite der soldatinnen und soldaten
stehen machen sie deutlich
in meinem leben
machen sie deutlich
das ist 16 jahre gefühliger
verteidigungsministerium das die bereit
sind diese fehler zu korrigieren und mit
der ampel gemeinsam daran arbeiten dass
wir die bundeswehr ausstatten das wäre
ein richtiges signal aus der union viele
nach spuren
der ordentlich zoff drin da im deutschen
bundestag hier der spd-chef last legen
weil zuvor der cdu-chef
unionsfraktionschef friedrich merz ein
heftiges wortgefecht dort es geht um die
deutschen waffenlieferungen für die
ukraine zu spät zu langsam zu zaudernd
immer wieder der vorwurf hier vor allen
dingen den kanzler an olaf scholz
heftige debatte dort